one of the biggest challenges that
asian-americans face is that they're
behind the scenes they don't wear to
passion under sleeves we don't put
ourselves out there and now we're just
not being seen for executive positions I
don't think there is enough Asian
American executives who are actually
asking for help there exist different
values between Asian family tradition
and American corporate culture system
the Asian American executives have had a
reputation for technical companies their
fundamental challenges are a sense of
invisibility leading teams taking risks
and speaking up I look at the program as
providing an opportunity for our
attendees to be even more successful in
their jobs it helped build my awareness
about the Asian tendencies that I have
we needed to do a better job being more
visible with my accomplishments the
program opens my eyes to this concept of
managing up and also exerting power it
gave you a different framework about how
you need to think about business when
you're at the upper tiers it's really
personal insights and awareness in terms
of what it takes to executive in
corporate levels it's really improved my
effectiveness at the office and proved
my executive communications the faculty
are world-class they really believe in
you and they want you to succeed the EOP
program moved my career from to the
c-level staff for a company and one of
the hottest areas of social analytics I
really believe that my recent promotion
was in part due to ALP it gave me the
tools and skills I needed to be
successful not only in this position but
in my future ones
you